tulsa gabriel represented the state of
hawaii in the congress as well as the
united states itself in the us army she
joins us now to assess what we're seeing
delicious garbage thanks so much for
coming on tonight so here you have the
government of ukraine complaining
because the president suggests that
maybe we're not going to go to war next
week
how distorted is our system
that we can be pushed into a potentially
nuclear
involved conflict by ukraine
well let's look at what's really at the
heart of what is motivating the
decisions being made by
our leaders in this country and what we
have is unfortunately democrats
republicans the mainstream media the
washington elite essentially in the
pocket of the military industrial
complex
and
rather than looking out for what's in
the best interests of the american
people our national security our country
they see dollar signs when they look at
ukraine they see
how they can line their pockets how they
can you know look tough how they can
posture themselves in a position where
they personally or politically or
financially benefit rather than actually
thinking about what are the costs and
consequences of these actions and who
pays the price it's the american people
and frankly the people of ukraine
so my guess is that some of the people
pushing for war don't actually want a
real war with russia it would tank our
economy in a second for one thing and
they'd be held responsible my concern is
they're so inept they so lack fine motor
skills that they're going to talk
themselves into getting us into a war
inadvertently they've got a long track
record of ineptitude are you worried
about that
i'm deeply concerned about that because
that that's very much the direction that
we are headed uh you know tucker i look
back to
early 2017
when then president trump said hey it
would be good if we got along with
russia you remember the reaction to that
everyone from you know democratic
leaders republican leaders people in the
mainstream media they said absolutely no
way there were people in trump's own
administration war mongers like john
bolton nikki haley mike pompeo who
outright rejected it and went on their
own agenda
and we're seeing the results of this now
we're seeing the result of how we have
continued to have these war mongers
escalating tensions putting us in this
disastrous position today leaving us the
american people uh with with frankly the
responsibility to stand up and say we
will not accept this we will not be
sheep allowing these war mongers in
washington to lead us down this very
very dangerous and costly path
i'll never forget when you came out as a
sitting member of congress and said well
maybe we shouldn't actually fight the
russians in syria and you were denounced
as a russian agent also is a racist for
not wanting to bomb another middle
eastern country which is my favorite
attack ever because it was so insane but
you paid a real cost for that i mean
they attacked you every day you served
in congress over that so it seems like
this is the red line for them you
criticize war and they won't stop in
their effort to destroy you
and and all of these threads we're
talking about here point back to that
core motivation motivation that sadly
does not lie in serving the best
interests of the american people our
security and our country it comes from a
very selfish place of how they can get
more power and get more money and who
they really work for it's not the
american people no it's certainly it's
certainly not that is absolutely right
thank you for saying that again you paid
a cost for it i appreciate it chelsea
gabbard good to see you hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else